[Music]
okay we just got done seeing bumblebee
which is a Transformers film I think
I've only seen one other Transformers
film because a while back
same people though Michael Bay right
Nikki directed this no think this is a
prequel is it not I must be yeah I think
it is because yeah it has to be because
it the stories taking place in the 80s
when 1887 right when they you know
around the time when the Transformers
actually came out was I think is a good
idea to the source material I I enjoyed
it I think it was actually a fun pretty
fun movie really good the visuals really
good and actually like I said there was
some like you know epic badass we're
about Fon sense yeah but it was mostly
concerned about the you know about
becoming to earth and like losing his
memory and getting all his voice broken
and he loss to do always he couldn't
talk anymore found a tragic hero yeah
and like his developing relationship
with the girl Charlie Watson who them
and be friends and stuff like that yeah
but it was a very yeah like I thought it
was cool as they said in 87 like urban
the transformers cartoons came out
pretty much non-stop cavalcade of red
eighties to nudge yeah and a lot of the
Smiths
there are Tears for Fears there are a
lot of a lot of ex generation Easter
eggs in that to your ex generation
coming up in that in that generation
yeah you just and you're right there
with it yeah several
you know several images to The Breakfast
Club
yeah that's yes if that was the only
thing I can say about this movie that
sometimes kind of what threw me out of
it is that it got kind of teen teenage
drama sappy and a couple of times and it
kind of slowed it down I thought but you
know the mean the main storyline is the
the invasion of Earth by these
Decepticons and you know
the the the Autobots are trying to set
up a temporary base because they got
kicked out of what was it called
Megatron savage on Cybertron so so that
the main story sometimes kind of gets
thrown in down it gets kind of set to
the side and so they go to a little bit
more of teenage drama but but the movies
doing that on purpose it knows it's
doing it they're showing you Easter eggs
of The Breakfast Club as it's doing it
and honestly this was I did be very
structured very much like an 80s teen
actually type maybe you're like a teen
movie with monsters in it yeah it had
very much that feeling I think Steven
Spielberg was actually mispredicted
risers on this and it feels like us yeah
his fingerprints all over it like the
way it's structured and stuff yeah and
the tone and everything so the movie did
do what it what it was designed yeah
yeah I enjoyed it it is yeah it's
actually really enjoyable it's very
light-hearted you know a feel-good movie
yeah it's like you know there's a bad
[ __ ] happens and there's likely to make
it through a lot of hero is a minute
it's kind of good values I guess you
could say we come through the movie
there's nothing in there for subversive
or you know thinking you think make you
feel bad in terms of you know and I mean
like hey that's not right
you know I mean things are rectified you
know this is a good flick and like I
said I'd like to I liked a lot of the
t-shirts that the girl was purchased
yeah she had a full Smith swatch it
called and lunch and yeah it's a saying
very very Gen X Gen X Easter eggs yeah
those little dark eighties houses
I forgot how dark those houses were I
know it's a little modern house yeah but
I don't know you know I hate to compare
movies it's up there with Aquaman but I
think I like the Aquaman a little bit
better it's kind of different kind of
movie yeah it's different
I don't even know if I could compare the
right it's it was [ __ ] epic and I
tell you what the voice acting for
Optimus Prime that sounded like the the
guy who did the animal voice but I
thought he was dead
that sounds like what whoever did that
voice this was that I like I said I
didn't haven't seen anything kind of big
Michael Bay Transformers movies um from
what I remember the one that I did see
it seemed very like I don't know like
slick and video game wish this really
doesn't look like that right um even the
robot fights and a lot of the robot
fights and transformations like take
place like just in the middle of the day
like interviewing or something like that
and it looks really realistic like a lot
of the robots like they would kind of
look beat up and dirty yet you know they
actually look like they're there it
doesn't look like think I saw him I
think I saw either the first or the
second and to me it was just kind of
forgettable it did it kind of lacks
character but now this one like I said
that you know it I thought it's good for
a character based yeah just like a big
visual epic I mean it had like big
visual epic things in it but it actually
like had a character I'm interested in
the censorship and story I'm interested
to see where it will go yeah you know
this if that another one comes out then
you know I'll watch that too
yeah just good movie yeah all right
you
okay we just got done soon uh
MARY POPPINS like their fathers turns
which is like the second part you told
Mary Poppins but wouldn't that come out
like the 60s I think it's been so long I
I've seen it but I ended it but just how
do I remember a long time
yeah I would this is actually very much
in line with the with a traditional
Disney type movie yeah I liked it it's
it's almost kind of like a throwback
movie there you see this movie they seem
to be trying to prove to some of the
naysayers that they can do what they
used to do it feels like a classic
Disney movie but they've really really
kind of upgraded the effects and I think
that he is a lot of weird stuff happens
the movie like they jump down into a
bathtub but they're in this weird
undersea world you know it's 19 it's
happening in the 1920s and in London so
it's it's a period piece to the another
time they jump into the painting on the
outside of a china bowl I really liked
that number that was a really cool yeah
actually cool part of that story was
actually my favorite part of it yeah but
the cool thing about this like I said
it's very much I remember quite a bit
about the original Disney Mary Poppins
with Julie Andrews this is very much the
same tone it's um it's uh even had a lot
of the same look to it yeah even the
animation because there are some
animated sequence sequences like I said
when when they went into the china bowl
and the whole world went animated it
looked just like the old-school Disney
animation from that era you know it made
it kind of it actually kind of reminded
me a little bit when it got a little bit
scary at that part it reminded me of the
old Disney um
Sleepy Hollow like my crane it looked
very much like that kind of thing with
the chase and the fire and everything
like that
the songs were all really good I really
liked
John who was obviously in on the new
James Bond the Daniel Craig James Bond
he's the new mmm no cute you mean yeah
he plays Q in the new James Bond meds so
he was in this playing like Michael
Banks who was the kid in the first there
he's grown up now
so it's grown-up him in the sister yeah
and then there's their kids and there's
some there's some cameos in there one
from like the original Mary Poppins and
there's also some you know there's a lot
of there's a lot of Angela Lansbury I
know guys that was still alive Steph I
was like look I'm good but yeah and
there was a like a lot of cool like
British theatrical and just like Julie
Walters wasn't as playing the
housekeeper like the bank's housekeeper
she was really good very caustic which
that's usually yeah but I I thought it
was a lot of fun yeah um you know like I
said it's a very very traditional so
they're pretty much just like a stage
musical yeah it's almost it's like
watching a Broadway show
right except yeah like big quality
quality performances was it was really
good the crowd seemed to enjoy it some
of the humor really wasn't there for me
but you know a comedy yeah right okay
next we had some Jack oh thanks doesn't
just kept laughing over every little
thing and I'm like dude man you're 65
what do you [ __ ] loud as you can
yeah well people worse yeah but yeah it
was a good movie I tell you why there
was a whole hell of a lot better than a
nutcracker I liked it much more
yeah and that cracker I don't know what
the hell that disaster was what it was
is that Disney tends to usually have a
pretty good ability to culturally
appropriate British and German stories
not so much Russia that thing did that
that didn't that Nutcracker story didn't
feel Russian at all though the thing is
I felt like it had too much I think and
we kind of already reviewed that but I
kind of felt like because it's a ballet
I think it works better is that rather
than like trying to go on this story on
to it this robots and which you know it
could have worked but it's just like I
said it looked cool it just didn't but
this one like I said very traditional
very much like the original so if you
like the original I don't see any and
it's partly made in England and had a
bunch of British actors in it too so you
don't mean it's yeah most of them just
British enough yeah yeah did you steal
your [ __ ] and gonna tell you what your
stories are gonna be well yeah they've
been doing that that's what that's
that's that was Walt Disney's gag going
all the way back you know well there he
made a lot of they had a lot of success
with fairy tales yeah and other like
British stories like I said the money
play story yeah their insidious my name
take your culture oh we gotta go
you
okay Jenny and I are here late at AMC we
just got done seeing mortal engines they
had a 10 o'clock showing because that
was all they're showing now I they're
probably gonna take it out of here soon
I guess so it's like midnight anyway
mortal engines is a futuristic
post-apocalyptic science fiction
adventure flick is that you call this
adventure action flick yeah and it's in
a future 1100 years from now where
cities are big basically rolling tanks
on treads
yeah and they run around a pretty lush
landscape actually when you looked at it
attacking and scavenging off of one
another they had alternate kinds of
cities they had ballooned cities kind of
like Bespin City with all these little
balloon ships and everything had some of
them that walked across the ocean or
through the ocean and you know it has to
have a steampunk look to it I would say
whereas Star Wars was kind of like a
retro futuristic 1930s this is like a
retro futuristic 1800s but they do have
you know computers and they're trying to
revive this quantum technology that they
found their blue tears yeah I had low
expectations for the movie but it was
pretty good
it actually was pretty good it's pretty
good like a lot of the same beats I
haven't read the book so I'm not sure
how good an adaptation of the book it is
but I mean you can tell that the book
probably went into like a [ __ ] ton more
detail but yeah Peter Jackson directed
this and the look of it is really really
nice you can tell he's like really
really went all out like trying to get
this world as detailed as possible with
all the world building and stuff like
that there was a lot of Star Wars
influence and I was just gonna say they
had Rory beats up sir probably from the
novel yeah they had a steampunk general
grievous they have a there was a Darth
Vader I'm your father a trope in it
would say probably one of the
differences though is that it's a
female-driven story yes god Walker is a
girl in this one and Princess Leia is a
boy and she knows that yeah he was the
helpless mare he was the helpless yes
true although was funny is that princely
it wasn't the helpless female she kicked
ass from the [ __ ] very beginning but
yeah than that it was a decent move yeah
I I it was actually pretty decent yeah I
wasn't I wasn't expecting one thing or
the other
I like I said I don't like to read
reviews of things before I hadn't really
heard much about this all you hear about
is Aquaman so and yeah this one wasn't
really sure how it was gonna be and I
haven't read the book so I mean I knew
the premise of the story but I didn't
really yeah it's gonna be and this one
only opened up on maybe two or three
weeks ago right and it looks like it's
on the way out of the theme maybe it was
a month it's been a while yeah it's I
hiked I expected it to be bad but it was
no they showed you some stuff that
you've never seen before it was actually
like pretty fast paced
pretty much kept on the run there was a
couple places where it got kind of sappy
and a little bit over emotional for me
but it wasn't too bad but really that
was only like a minute or two right now
and then like I said there wasn't a lot
of conversation really it's like there
was some exposition Airy stuff but it
mostly like kept moving from one action
sequence to another and it's not really
sure the way to send it if things were
actually resolved so there's probably
this I could tell they were this was
written to be yes so I'm not sure if the
book is a standalone earth it's part of
a series I had the impression it was
part of a series but I could be thinking
of another way to send if I'm under the
impression that this is going to be a
series thank you feel like it probably I
mean I feel like it did resolve
satisfactorily but it left it open and
if certain people were dead or not yeah
like you know what I mean but it left it
open enough that you know they could
make sure the hell a lot better than
Robin Hood women I thought was terrible
it just wasn't I don't know it just
didn't it didn't grab me it was just
kind of like all right whatever wasn't
as good as Aquaman but it did it wasn't
bad it was good yeah one of the better
month we got to get out of here
[Music]